[music]
today we gave the
ministers the final
progress report on the reform of the
common agricultural policy and the
austrian presidency of the council, with
which sufficient account is taken of the positions and concerns of the
member states with
regard to the new implementation model
and its performance aspects, as is
clear from the member states
that on the one hand you can
support this system change in principle
, but that above all further
improvements are required one
of the most important dossiers is
the directive against unfair
commercial practices we want a
fair system for the agricultural and
food sector that
rewards farmers for quality
[music]